[Musique]
vous êtes à l'écoute de la
source numéro un de radio free america pour les nouvelles de
la résistance,
les sanctions mondiales contre Galaad se multiplient alors
que la dernière vague de violence se poursuit,
peu importe où la guerre vous trouve aujourd'hui,
rappelez-vous simplement que
nous sommes toujours là, personne ne va
gardez-nous au sol gardez-nous au
palais de
justice personne ne va nous retenir nous savons
comment voler
elle est là-bas en train de planifier qui sait quel
genre d'atrocités rendre visite à notre
nation juste la trouver et l'amener
à moi
[Musique]
ensemble à
peine
il ne peut pas la sauver